we humans are becoming an urban species
so cities they are our natural habitat
that is where we live in 2014 over 54%
of the world population was living in
cities and I can bet you that so many of
these people have thought of how they
would do things differently like if I
only had the tools to change things in
my city what would I do what would my
dream city be like and these tools this
is just what we gave them
two years ago my team and I we're gonna
lose the game city skylines it is a game
about building cities so I have always
been interested in cities as systems
it's something that I find immensely
interesting but what I didn't understand
was that I am not alone in this people
love cities they are interested they
have ideas the game was an instant hit
so far over three and a half million
people have played it and it's not just
about playing we also have had only
awesome sharing systems so people play
they create cities and then they are
sharing these creations showing off what
they have made and what I will show you
is is some of this is needed by the
players so the game is about
self-expression creativity not just
overcoming the challenges posed by the
simulation it is about showing what your
cities look like so I have a couple of
videos these are from YouTube and these
are some of the most interesting city
designs that I have seen so
they're all different and I hope you
like all of these this one is called the
Netherlands it's by Silva and when you
start the game you you have an empty
piece of land this land it can be based
on the real world it can be handcrafted
in the map editor or you can of course
download a city made by someone else and
play on that but what silver and has
done here is that what he wanted to make
was not not a real city the this is a
fantasy city even though it looks real
so what he wanted to do was a fantasy
city that could be in the Netherlands so
he kind of investigated what on the
characteristics of cities in the
Netherlands and combined a couple of
those and that's this is what he created
so it's it is a city that is is not a
real city but it could be it looks just
like the others
so the place is really densely populated
so what you need is highways drawings
anything connecting these small town
centers together lots of people lots of
moving so transportation is the key here
but then let's go even more on the
fantasy side let's go into the future
this is one of my personal favorites
this city designs are what I I love the
most
so this is a tiered city by conflict
note and the basic idea is that you have
call central circle routes so so the
city is a big circle with tiny encircles
inside and thing is that you put all of
the services in the center and then
people actually live on the outer ring
because there's less traffic less noise
less pollution so that is where you want
to live but the service is a still
really close by they are in the center
and this is the soul of the game
the player has to understand what are
the wishes what are the needs of the
tiny people living in the cities so you
need to know where you should put the
things like it's not enough to have a
hospital it needs to be accessible
citizens need to reach the hospital and
that this is one way to do it so maybe
this is something that we might be
seeing someday and then even more into
the future Estonia by Yuto so you told
us YouTube videos and place the game
what he did here was actually a 12-pound
series of creating this city so what he
does is he he plays the game he record
it and he explains as he's going what he
is doing and why and as a part of this
series he actually did an interview with
an actual urban planner called Jeff
speck and spec is an expert on the
concept of walkability the the basic
idea is that if you want citizens to
walk which is kind of beneficial you
actually need to have walking as as a
reasonable means of transportation
it should be a good way to age places so
what you thought did was that he
explained its concept
he had spec explained to and then he
applied it to the city that he was
building so what we are seeing is youth
those vision of the future lots of
public transportation walkways plazas
connecting high-rise buildings maybe
this is what the future might look like
and and the game system works really
well for this we are seeing some real
world uses to this game so we know that
some urban planners are using it as a
sketching tool so while the simulation
is not completely realistic it is
realistic enough that if something works
in the game it is highly likely that it
will also work in the real world
so that you can actually try out things
see if this intersection might fit this
kind of a situation if we build a new
road would it help and this is what you
can do with this game there was one
really interesting contest held by the
finished city of Hamelin
so what they did was that they had a new
area that I wanted to develop in the
city they made a map with the existing
city they left empty the area that they
will want to develop and shared this map
so anyone could download the map play
the game built the area and submit their
creations to the City Council so they
have not yet built anything but it might
just be that they they use one of these
plans made with the game to to actually
build the real City and the this videos
that I have shown you the these are the
people who are coming up with new kinds
of solutions we know that cities are
growing they are getting bigger as we go
and the percentage of population living
in cities is projected to rise so we
need the solutions and these people
playing the game they are trying out
different kinds of solutions they might
have something that is really important
so what what we are seeing here is James
it is that might be real one day so it
might be that this is not just again it
might be a way to decide our fate thank
you
[Applause]